et nous sommes avec jérémie chef
d'entreprise vous avez aussi beaucoup
travaillé avec l'azerbaïdjan et françois
pupponi député modem du val d'oise vice
président du groupe d'amitié
france-arménie à l'assemblée bonsoir
messieurs et merci de participer à cet
échange ce soir françois pupponi vous
avez appelé la france à agir rapidement
quel regard est ce que vous portez sur
la prise de parole hier d' emmanuel
macron la salue parce que moi tu rentres
d'arménie du haut karabagh où j'ai pu
constater effectivement li lé prenantes
il persiste après la guerre du haut
karabagh et avec le risque qu'ils
étaient déjà annoncé par nos amis
arméniens de la volonté des azéri de
rentrer au sud dans la région du sud
pour faire une voie entre la turquie et
l'azerbaïdjan et on sait très bien que
la volonté de d'erdogan et d'aliev c'est
de faire cette voie là ils sont rentrés
sur les territoires arméniens ce qui est
une violation des frontières arméniennes
donc les russes et les français qui sont
tous les américains qui sont tous les
trois coprésidents du fameux groupe de
minsk qui est là pour essayer de mettre
de la paix depuis trente ans entre
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie par rapport
au karabakh sont intervenus pour
demander aux azéri de se retirer du
d'arménie est retourné à l'intérieur de
leurs frontières
donc c'est ce qu'on espère sinon
malheureusement on ira de nouveau vers
un conflit qui sera un conflit sanglant
et gérer mais comment de votre côté ce
que vous avez accueilli à ces mots du
chef de l'état comment est-ce que vous
jugez la position la posture de la
france dans ce conflit qui oppose
l'arménie l'azerbaïdjan
moi je crois que la position de la
france pour être pour être efficace il
faut qu'elle quelle soit qu'elles soient
équilibrés c'est l'intérêt de toutes les
parties
l'arménie en premier lieu parce que sur
le court terme comme sur le long terme
prendre parti dans un conflit qui en
suit ainsi compliqué c'est finalement
allez alors à l'encontre de nos intérêts
de notre présence dans la zone puisque
finalement là l'armée dit on à d'une
attache tout à fait particulière
historique culturel et ancien avec une
communauté française très très bien
assimilé implantés en france
et puis l'azerbaïdjan qui est un pays
qui je considérais maltraités très très
mal traités et je dirais que si on met
ce jeu vous voyez je connais
parfaitement vos positions en france sur
le risque que représente la menace
islamiste x et je vais vous dire je
partage totalement et pourquoi j'ai dit
qu'on se tire une balle dans le pied
c'est que le risque de faire de prendre
à partie et reposerait sur un choix
culturel religieux pays l'arménie
chrétienne la verbal genre musulmans et
bien c'est ça correspond d'une part pas
une réalité c'est un conflit territorial
national
et s'il ya un pays qui est le seul du
monde musulman aujourd'hui c'est
l'azerbaïdjan est une série en
azerbaïdjan je ne sais pas si vous avez
été le monsieur boni mais lorsqu'un pays
où il ya moins de comme je suis interdit
de ces fonds blacklisté corps mais vous
êtes un geek de tv il y avait et ce que
je veux dire c'est que c'est un pays où
il ya moins de femmes voilées capable
d'un coup et quand elles sont voilées la
plupart du temps ce sont des turcs qui
travaillent là bas c'est un pays laïc et
quand l'azerbaïdjan par exemple en
france subventionne quelque chose c'est
pas une mosquée ça a aidé par exemple
les vitraux de la cathédrale de
strasbourg
donc les choses sont pas simples vous
avez parmi les l'azerbaïdjan je crois
paix dont l'opinion publique et dans la
classe politique française le fait que
danser ces dernières années son allié
principal
ça a été la turquie et qui effectivement
je ne voudrais pas que l'azerbaïdjan
soit une victime collatérale de
des du contentieux qui nous oppose à la
turquie et je comprends bien le lamanage
c'est l'atelier la sortie sur emi ni
terra les mêmes en france il ya ces
moyens d'affluence voilà donc je vois je
crois qu'il faudrait pas se tromper de
combat
l'intérêt de 2,2 tous ça serait sachet
de de garantir aujourd'hui le
cessez-le-feu la paix ces accords qui
ont été signés à moscou doivent être
consolidés je pense qu'on a raté une
grande occasion diplomatique
c'est que quand la ce conflit de bébé
est arrivé jeudi du mois de septembre
je crois qu s'ils sont ce qui aurait
fallu faire c'est que le président de la
république s'envola moustrou c'est
qu'avec poutine y convoque les deux
présidents ou tout cas le président
l'azerbaïdjan et le premier ministre
pashinian et je crois que c'est le pays
qui sont très écoutés très respecté
aurait obtenu le cessez-le-feu et un
accord qui alors encore peut-être même
sur les faits avant aurait permis au
karabagh de vivre dans un statut de
préserver par des grandes puissances
d'autonomie très très poussée moi je
pense même qu à une époque était
possible d'avoir un statut pour le
karabagh ou la décla la fiorentina 0
beihdja neige pour dorer portait
uniquement sur les relations
diplomatiques et sur la défense et que
karabakh aurait vu sa vie ni les puces
harry avec un corridor qui lui aurait
permis de communiquer autant qu'il se
perd avec l'arménie voilà donc moi je je
je je suis en conflit avec personne je
pense tout simplement que que j'aime
leur midi également et je pense que le
meilleur le meilleur service qu'on
puisse rendre à au caucase à l'arménie à
l'azerbaïdjan
ben c'est de consolider la paix et ça ça
devrait être une de nos priorités france
un peu paumé pour revenir sur les propos
tenus à l'instant tu as ta vie de rémi
vous dirais que ce sont des
considérations religieuses qui guide les
prises de position à des manuels macro
est ce que d'ailleurs ce louvre il doit
aller plus loin que d'afficher son
soutien au peuple arménien est alors de
quelle manière
il ya bien sûr il ya bien un aspect
religieuse et moi j'irai m j'étais haut
karabagh il ya quinze jours j'ai tant
dormi ya quinze jours donc sincèrement
quand on est en train de détruire des
églises qui sont là depuis plusieurs
centaines d'années parce qu'on occupe le
territoire
il ya un aspect religieux ces temps là
mais la vraie question qui est posée
aujourd'hui on pas se tromper on là vous
me dépeignez laser batian comme étant le
pays le plus beau pays du monde
il ya quand même deux sujets aujourd'hui
qui sont au réel l'azerbaïdjan est
rentré à l'intérieur de l'arménie donc
ils sont rentrés
contrairement au cessez-le-feu qui a été
obtenu par moscou de quel droit
l'azerbaïdjan rentrer en a remis pour
occuper une partie de leur nid là on
parle plus du haut karabagh ils sont en
arménie actuellement ce soir 1 et
deuxièmement par rapport à la guerre qui
est l'une des 44 jours récemment il ya
encore 250 prisonniers qui n'ont pas été
rendus si l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
veut vraiment être ce pays et
l'idyllique laïque respectueux du droit
qu'il rend les prises de guerre qui les
rendent le plus vite possible
conformément aux textes internationaux
et qu'il ne rentre pas militairement
chez son voisin arménien parce que là il
est en train d'attaquer leur mini sont
entrés en arménie donc moi je veux bien
qu'on parle de paix mais quand on fait
la paire on n'occupe pas les autres
voilà donc aujourd'hui il faut que
l'azerbaïdjan se retire de l'arménie il
faut effectivement qu'ils rendent les
prisonniers qu'ils fassent attribuez
vous me disiez mais ce que je suis allé
en algérie à bakou jamais je suis
interdit de séjour voilà dès qu'on met
les pieds en aksar et qu'on ait des
défenseurs des dépôts carabins eh bien
on est blacklisté par ahmad gens qui
considèrent qu'on n'a pas à s'occuper de
la star pour les faire de l'humanitaire
salle au débat mais voilà donc faut pas
non plus à inverser les rôles
aujourd'hui de l'agresseur c'est
l'azerbaïdjan alors qu'ils arrêtent de
rentrer en harmonie qu'ils rendent les
prisonniers effectivement qu'il s'engage
dans un processus de paix avec un statut
pour le haut karabakh
parce que ont péri qu'après vont-ils
s'engager à respecter l'ensemble des
lieux de culte qu'ils occupent tactique
qui sont aujourd'hui après la guerre des
44 jours en territoire azerbaïdjanais
il n'aura pas intérêt est ce qu'ils
s'engagent à les respecter et à ne pas
détruire des églises
régner quel quelles peuvent être les
conséquences et l'impact aussi de prises
de position comme celle du président
français à la fournaise herbe adjoint et
en armani puis dans les relations entre
contrôlé entre les deux oui je vois que
j'aurais quand même lire aujourd'hui on
n'est pas à la veille d'une nouvelle
guerre à l'est et des juges et regardé
le communiqué des hurlements algérie
s'il n'ya pas qu'ils sont entre
l'arménie qui se sait qu'ils étaient en
jaune frontières et que ce serait les
amériques rendre en arménie les russes
disent qu'ils seront en train d'armer ni
les français
les trois co présidents du groupe 2010
qui se rentrent en arménie bon donc ça
veut dire que poutine
baillet malraux se trompent non non ce
que je veux dire c'est que nous allons
tous intérêts et toutes les fautes tous
les pays vous avez cité de participer de
ne pas reconduire encore cet échec du
groupe de minsk qui en 30 ans n'a rien
fait parce que je rappelle quand même
qu'aujourd'hui les azéris on sera
territoire que la communauté
internationale leur connaît non pas
quand il rentre en jeu est pas corrézien
la route prise par le conseil du
dispostif le louer ou non d'accord je
parle pas d'incursion éventuelles sur la
frontière qui je le répète son sont
démenties par l'azerbaïdjan et qui
serait inacceptable oléronnais d'accord
ce serait ça serait inacceptable
simplement c'est que il faudrait pas
qu'à l'avenir on vive une espèce de
l'échappée l'espèce de 2,2 en permanence
de de fait armées avant tout cas avec
des risques qui fait avec une
possibilité de dégénérer la situation
dégénère parce que les accords de
cessez-le-feu qui ont été signés au mois
de novembre
amossy doivent être mises en oeuvre ils
sont pas claires je pense que la france
elle devrait prendre toute sa part on
est partagé la guerre même fille voilà
et et parce que le diable se cache dans
les détails
pourquoi les azéri et elle a
certainement pour identifier ce qui est
prévu dans les accords c'est à dire une
voie de passage une route qui doit
permettre des erreurs qu'avec la piche
evans et qui devrait ensuite permettrait
la tuerie d'accéder à
centrales et donc ça ça fait partie de
ce statut du karabakh n'est toujours pas
n'est toujours pas fixée par les accords
et donc moi je pense qu'on a tous à
gagner je pense à la russie à la france
emprunte prioritairement pour y
participer alors certains diront c'est
peut-être trop tard parce que c'est vrai
que notre nous le sommes affaiblis la
diplomatie française c'est que ces s'est
affaiblie dans la dernière période
rappelle que tous les présidents avaient
maintenu un équilibre en termes par
exemple de voyage officiel que ce soit
sarkozy je sois hollande on allait à bas
coûts est on allé à gran et en 2019 et
là c'est pour des raisons qu'ils étaient
des raisons qui dépanne diplomatique
mais qui ont été peut-être mal adapté du
bottin azerbaïdjanais le président
français est rentré après erevan parce
qu'il a été ministre de l'intérieur
depuis qu'un lourd bon cgt mais en tout
cas chez d'état précédent diplomatique
la politique de la france de longue date
était effectivement un équilibre je
penchais laquelle les qu'elle est
rachetée mais c'était un signe qui nous
a qui nous a affaiblis et qui affaiblit
malheureusement les temps nous manque
je vous fait réagir françois pontonnier
ce sera le mot de la fin on aura
l'occasion de prolonger revenir sur ce
débat d'entre deux prochaines éditions
françois pupponi comment la france
doit-elle prendre toute sa part pour
reprendre les termes de jean rémy que
vous sembliez à prouver oui
effectivement que le groupe demi se
retrouve toute sa place et la france en
premier et qu'elle arrête avec sa
neutralité
parce que la neutralité ça a conduit à
la guerre de 44 jours et avec quasiment
la disparition on a failli perdre le
look à rabat afin d' axa re l'appui que
otto perez d'axa donc je pense que la
france doit reprendre sa place avec les
états unis qui n'ont pas été très
présent dans le goût de mise depuis
quelques années aujourd'hui ceux qui
assurent la paix sur le terrain ce sont
les russes
moi quand je suis allé au caravage et
dieu il ya eu 4 checkpoint russe pour
rentrer au karabagh donc effectivement
ce sont les russes qui heureusement
assure la paix dans cette partie du
caucase et donc il faut que la france et
les etats-unis mais parlons de la france
reprennent leur place
après si on veut parler de paix je ne
suis pas sûr je répète il faut que les
azéris rangs des prisonniers de guerre
ça fait partie des règles
internationales
lorsqu'il ya un conflit on rend les
prisonniers de guerre aux familles il
faut qu'ils évitent de rendre en arménie
parce que comment voulez vous que la
paix viennent et comment vous les
arméniens ne réagissent pas lorsque les
azéris qui après la guerre de 34 jours
entre maintenant en arménie serviolles
des frontières c'est pas comme ça qu'on
va faire la paix et effectivement que le
goût de miss retrouve sa place donc je
pense qu'effectivement il faut pas non
plus dire que les la france moi je
considère que la france était trop
neutre dans tout ce dispositif et que
c'est pour ça que lagarde 44 jours a eu
lieu et que le haut karabagh a failli en
fin de compte la république
autoproclamée d'axa re a failli
disparaître
heureusement que ce n'a pas été le cas
et qu'elle continue à exister après oui
il faut effectivement se mettre autour
d'une table
il faut essayer de travailler et pour
avoir une paix durable mais ça passe
mais ça passe et c'est pour ça qu'on ait
voté une résolution à l'assemblée
nationale ça passe par une
reconnaissance de la république
autoproclamée de laksar parce que c'est
à ce titre là on pourra on pourra
comment on aura l'occasion mais si on
aura l'occasion de donner la france
était chaleureux merci à tous les deux
messieurs d'avoir participé à cet
échange suis obligé de vous couper navré
françois pupponi député modem du val
d'oise vice président du groupe d'amitié
france-arménie à l'assemblée et gilles
rémy chef d'entreprise merci à tous les
deux d'avoir participé à ce débat et à
très bientôt sur rt france